bye-bye batfleck this is the dawning of
the age of Pattinson after much
speculation about she would replace Ben
Affleck as Bruce Wayne and director Matt
Reeves as the Batman we finally know who
the lucky actor is Robert Pattinson
sources close to Variety have noted that
Pattinson who broke into the mainstream
with the Twilight franchise and the
since gone on to make a major name for
himself in the drama genre and with
arthouse films as in final negotiations
of studio Warner Brothers to top-line
the feature as a titular DC Comics hero
the ink on the contract hasn't dried
just yet but the deal is expected to
close soon it's hard to explain I need
you to be open-minded can you do that
Warner Brothers declined to comment on
the news but it looks like Pattinson
will take flight to become the Caped
Crusader before too long as a Batman is
slated to start pre-production sometime
this summer and could go in front of
cameras either late this year or early
next the many who have kept their
fingers on the pulse of all things
related to the Batman learning that
pattern Sun is about to rise as a new
Bruce Wayne and assume the mantle from
Affleck who dropped out of the Batman as
its director and that star comes as
little surprise rumors have been
swirling for months now and at one point
gained so much traction the artists
began crafting digital works envisioning
what the English actor would look like
in the pad suit and dressed up in Black
Tie attire as a billionaire Bruce Wayne
other actors including Army hammer
Logan Lerman Jack O'Connell Ansel Elgort
Dylan O'Brien Aaron taylor-johnson nois
Antonio Richard Madden and Kit Harington
were reported contenders for the leading
role in the Batman but it's clear that
Pattinson was the favorite Warner
Brothers and Reeves evidently loved
Pattinson so much that they've tapped
him before the final version of the film
script as even completes it's true right
now Reeves are still polishing the story
before locking it in but he apparently
couldn't wait to secure Pattinson before
then Reeves was said to be scouting for
an actor 15 to 20 years younger than
Affleck who's in his mid 40s Pattinson
fits that age range nicely according to
Variety Warner Brothers as giving Reeves
as much time as needed to make the
Batman as perfect as possible starting
with the script and the cast the studio
reportedly hopes that this version of
the famed DC vigilante makes up for how
the character was depicted in Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice and Justice
League Reeves previously described as
take on the iconic superhero as an
almost no are driven detective version
of Batman and the film as a whole is
being influenced by the
works of Alfred Hitchcock Reeves told
The Hollywood Reporter in June of 2017
what I try to do is use a camera and use
a storytelling so that you become that
character and you emphasize to that
point of view there's a chance to do a
version of Batman that is point-of-view
driven in a very very powerful way that
will hopefully connect you to what's
going on inside of his head and inside
of his heart too many Pattinson is still
and a Louis B Edward Cullen from The
Twilight Saga but the actor has done
some genuinely fantastic work in the
time after the five movie fantasy
romance franchise wrapped in 2012
Pattinson went from glittering in the
Washington State Sun as a brooding
vampire the dazzling in films like the
lost city of said good time and High
Life Pattinson is set to appear in the
lighthouse the king and waiting for the
barbarians in 2019 alone the Batman is a
project unlike anything Pattinson has
done in his career thus far and gives
the actor whose biggest film role will
likely always precede him a chance to
show millions of people who haven't kept
up with his post Twilight work but he's
more than just the vampire guy Pattinson
does have a lot to live up to
since many actors have played Batman
before him but the potent combination of
his sharpened acting chops his status as
a sort of underdog and the positive
responses casting in the Batman has
already received hints that he'll more
than live up to expectations
I'm Batman the Batman hits theaters on
June 25th 2021 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the DC EU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]